good morning Hank it's Tuesday today I
want to tell you a story about this
stuff honey badger and my son and I also
want to tell you the best news ever but
first it's time for the Bank of
nerdfighteria quarterly report so I
guess I should get dressed up and done
so Hank as you know the Bank of
nerdfighteria has two arms the lending
arm and the giving arm a lot of banks
have a third arm the taking arm but we
believe that two arms is enough well
unless you're juggling then a third arm
is super helpful
let's begin our report with the giving
arm the foundation to decrease worldsuck
update 1 Hank the foundation to decrease
worldsuck has been a project of
nerdfighter for more than 5 years but we
are finally becoming an actual charity
like that you can make tax-deductible
donations too so that process is ongoing
and very complicated update to
financials right so at the end of the
last quarter the foundation to decrease
worldsuck at more than nine thousand
dollars in its coffers and today we have
like 30 dollars in our coffers which
represents a tremendous success because
the whole story is that we went from
nine thousand to eighty eight thousand
to nothing because we gave all the money
away more than sixteen thousand five
hundred dollars was sent to each of five
charities which were chosen by
nerdfighteria they were kids in need of
desks this star won't go out the HP
Alliance water.org on the other one
what's the other Oh Kiva right the
operating cost of the foundation to
decrease worldsuck continued to be zero
so every dollar donated goes to charity
by the way I think I like that my puff
ends right where yours begins it's like
it's like a puff portal so nerdfighters
thanks for all your hard work during the
project for awesome and look how much
suck we decreased and now we come to the
second arm of the Bank of nerdfighteria
the lending arm so Hank kiva.org is this
amazing website that nerdfighters have
been using for many years that allows
regular people to make loans to
entrepreneurs in the developing world so
basically I'll own for instance Edgar in
Peru money so he can increase the yield
on his land or Henry in South Sudan
money so he can buy more supplies for
his store and then they pay me back
basically giving developing world
entrepreneurs access to the same kind of
inexpensive credit and banking systems
that the rest of us benefit from and
frankly kind of take for granted and the
coolest part is that 99% of the time you
get paid back actually that used to be
the coolest part that's now the second
coolest part but I'll get to the coolest
part in a second okay so in the last
quarter the nerdfighter Kiva group has
gone from 75,000
and loans to $239,000 in loans which
represents a quarterly increase of like
a gajillion percent actually 319 percent
of just G chatted with resident
mathematician Daniel Biss our Kiva group
now has over 9,000 members over 9,000
members anybody huh does that mean too
old and that joke too subtle sorry
and right now Hank we're near the top of
total amount loaned this month
comfortably situated between the
atheists and the Christians but
nerdfighters that is not even the best
news here is the best news if you are
not currently a member of Kiva and you
are one of the next 20,000 people to
become a member I am pointing at my
pants because there is a link in the
doobly-doo you will be given a free loan
well it won't be free it'll be paid for
by one of the cofounders of LinkedIn but
it will be free to you thanks to this
guy's generosity it costs you nothing to
become an awesome banker you can go
right now and make a $25.00 go into an
entrepreneur in the developing world for
free hopefully nerdfighters have lots of
you take advantage of that our group
will grow even more and you will
discover the wonders of microfinance and
everything will be beautiful and nothing
will hurt I got to tell you a story
about a honey badger
so make when we were on tour a
nerdfighter gave me this homemade honey
badger and Henry has become completely
obsessed with it and Henry basically
only has two questions about everything
in the world whether it's an airplane or
a person what sound does it make and
what does it eat so I told them the
truth that if you hear the sound a honey
badger makes it's too late for you and
that honey badgers eat everything so he
interpreted that second answer very
broadly like whatever we can't find the
remote he's always like honey badger eat
it and when you try to explain to him
the extinction of the dinosaurs he's
like honey badger eat dinosaurs all of
which is to say Hank that when I asked
Henry what he thought the universe had
no edge I knew how he'd answer but I was
still delighted that's right Hank honey
badger ate the edge I'll see you on
Friday